Construction has just begun
Indian company Tata is investing 1.5
billion euros in a new car factory on
this huge tract of land near Bratislava
they'll be building cars for the
traditional Jaguar and Land Rover brands
the factory will create 1500 new jobs
around 35,000 job seekers have already
applied for work most of the applicants
come from the region around the
Slovakian capital where business has
been booming this is a feature of Slovak
people that they are not really willing
to move or to travel but - they work it
is it is a social or social fact that
it's it's quite difficult to find
accommodation for therefore whole family
if you live in a house in a village in
these of Slovakia the price of half of a
house is much lower than the price of a
single flat here or apartment here in
the west of Slovakia but commutes to
work within the country are getting
easier the European Union invests 2.5
billion euros in Slovakia annually the
money is used primarily to improve the
country's infrastructure most of the
country's highways are brand new
German company Leonie arrived in
Slovakia almost 20 years ago it produces
components like cables for the car
industry low salaries have made the area
interesting to investors at the moment
Leonie is looking for 250 new staff
members but competition for the best
employees is growing especially since
Jaguar and Land Rover have arrived in
Slovakia site manager egoist Rajic is
grateful for every skilled worker he can
find and his strategies appear to be
working one of them for example is
keeping skilled workers by raising their
salaries that's how we motivate them to
remain loyal to the company 300
kilometers to the east the new highways
are nowhere to be found the money
provided by the EU ran out before they
could be completed local politician Luba
Mir Motyka
has watched his village in the mountains
fall apart most people here are
unemployed anti-eu political parties are
popular and the young people in the
village just want to get out what are
they done for us nothing it's just the
same as it ever was
there's nothing going on here EU money
has been used to renovate the school and
pave the central square but that all
happened four years ago local
politicians are now hoping for more
financial aid so the economy can take
off in this region as well Sempra casa
umoja
it's hard to get companies to settle
here the infrastructure needs to be
expanded then we'll be able to attract
small and mid-sized companies too but
small businesses have an especially
difficult time getting EU financing
honey producer do's and Ed insky found
out the hard way
he applied for 5,000 euros to turn this
space into a schoolroom for children
he's been applying for the money every
year Brussels has spent billions for
highways but keeps ignoring his modest
request he complains the bureaucracy is
endless I'd be better off just getting
on with my work and forgetting about the
EU applications further east towards coe
she'd say
marek love chuck manages the startup
scene here the city is providing
high-speed Internet connections and
4,500 software specialists from the
German Telecom subsidiary are making use
of them the University employee brings
people together starts up small
businesses and rents cheap office space
for creative people in the city some are
producing high-tech products like this
circuit board and big international
companies are already interested in
buying a sound system that was developed
here more than 10 thousand new jobs in
IT are up for grabs here in Kosice it's
an economic success story
even without EU subsidies startups have
had to provide their own momentum
Brussels is just too far away the
problem with you money is that you have
to wait very long
also bureaucracy around all you funds is
quite difficult so we've decided to stay
on our own even though Slovakia started
out as one of the poorest countries in
the region it has now developed a
dynamic economy and a decisive factor in
that success has been the infrastructure
programs financed by the European Union
you